bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire et alors qu'approche donc les
élections départementales et régionales
est ce que vous êtes favorable ou vote
par correspondance
non j'y suis opposée g reste opposée si
on a arrêté le vote par correspondance
et parce que c'est une source de fraude
et de fraudes importantes
j'entendais un collègue diront peu
sécurisé c'est pas vrai elle qui a
changé les yaourts vient toujours un
envoi par la pose à la fois
que vous allez recevoir et celui
goût réexpédier et si on la supprime et
c'est justement parce que c'était une
sorte de fraudes importantes on a
développé le dock par procuration je
pense qu'on peut le développer encore
d'ailleurs par exemple en donnant la
possibilité à une personne de porter
deux ou trois autres curation en vous
obligeant pas habiter la même commune
que la personne qui vous donne
procuration parce que vous avez besoin
de trouver quelqu'un de confiance et
peut-être que vous ne trouvez pas dans
votre commune mais le vote par
correspondance je le répète est une
source de fraude sauf à demander aux
gens de venir se signaler pour voter
physiquement portée par correspondance a
demandé eux mêmes d'avoir une enveloppe
qui leur soit remise mais dans ces cas
là c'est franchement c'est la même chose
que devenir l'hôte et donc ça n'a pas
grand intérêt pas grande chance je me
demande d'ailleurs quelques
arrière-pensées saisi la majorité pour
essayer de mettre en place
seul parce que personne n'y semblent
favorables 1 vote par correspondance qui
je le répète a été supprimée en france
parce que c'est très facile de frauder
avec ce type de vote
le timing est étonnant aussi à proposer
ce vote par correspondance en france
quand on voit ce que ça donne aux états
unis avec ses soupçons de fraude c'est
là une maladresse selon vous je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas je comparerais pas
le système électoral américain qui est
assez bordélique ont à dire pour être
gentil au site français qui fonctionne
qui permet de voter parce que même qui
permet de voter par procuration et
trouver le prétexte entre guillemets de
l'abstention pour dire ah si on
faciliter la vie aux gens par
correspondance
ça correspond bien sûr à une toute
petite part des lecteurs
mais les marginal le désintérêt il est
plus lié les difficultés politiques dans
le débat politique que dans le mode de
vote dans s'il ya une possibilité
d'avancer par un vote différent ce
serait peut-être je dis bien peut-être
sur le vote
par le vote électronique ont fait
aujourd'hui beaucoup de courses beaucoup
d'échangés financiers vous payer par
internet
donc on est capable d'identifier capable
de sécuriser votre compte bancaire etc
ça je pense que c'est sans doute
envisageable ce que je ne sais pas c'est
si on permettait d'identification de
l'électeur et le vote de l'électeur par
internet qui paraît beaucoup plus
sécurisé keyvelop souvent ben là je ne
sais pas si on est capable d'assurer que
mon bulletin de vote va être bien
content et entendait bien que si sur mon
ordinateur je prêche sur la touche baden
je veux pas que ya un logiciel qui
transforme sa de temps en temps votre
fringue on est capable de sécuriser
l'identité des genres électroniquement
est ce qu'on est capable de sécuriser à
la fois la confidentialité de leurs
bottes et le respect de leur vote ça
j'en suis moins sûr
en tout cas aujourd'hui on a un système
de vote qui fonctionne bien on n'a pas
le bazar des états unis les électeurs
n'y viennent pas c'est la banque
d'attractivité des candidats mais à les
développer un système qui développerait
inem
inévitablement la fraude je pourrais
vous le démontrer très facilement me
paraîtrait une grave erreur
de plus en matière électorale de la part
de cette majorité
un tout dernier mot selon les partisans
de ce vote par correspondance
le dispositif permettrait
de lutte et d'éviter l'abstention quelle
autre solution
selon vous pour inciter les français à
aller voter notamment dans ce contexte
on le rappelle le crise sanitaire
ces banques et pas d'abstention pour de
voir que les candidats soient attractifs
et quand les gens ne croient pas aux
candidats c'est pas parce que vous allez
leur permettre de le faire
électroniquement ou par correspondance
qui viendront voter
premier élément deuxième élément
j'aurais si vous voulez un vote par
correspondance sécurisé il faut d'abord
que la personne vienne par exemple dans
un commissariat de police
faire constater qu' elle ne sera pas là
jour là des problèmes de santé de sa
crème du coc vide l'empêchent de venir
le jour du vote mais très franchement si
elles valent un commissariat de police
ou à la gendarmerie pour signaler
qu'elle préfèrerait voté par
correspondance elle peut aller voter le
jour du vote
ici elle n'est pas là à ce moment là il
ya le système des pros argent c'est donc
un mode c'est cette démagogie ambiante
qui fait croire que c'est la technique
qui va empêcher les gens de venir voter
non la crainte du virus elle peut
parfaitement existé mais dans ces cas là
la procuration suffit amplement
parce que le problème du vote par
correspondance c'est que vous faites
passer des millions dans blog qui vous
permettent de voter par la poste
beaucoup d'entre elles n'arrivent pas à
des signataires rien ne garantit la
confidentialité lieu
rien ne garantit que des gens vont pas
aller récupérer des enveloppes auprès
des électeurs aient voté à leur place en
échange de services
c'est tout ça qui se passait avant
france - j'ai fait maire d'une ville gmr
d'une norme aussi louis trente six mille
électeurs 3000 des enveloppes qu'on en
voit habituellement aux électeurs
revenait à la mairie vous imaginez la
source de fraude que ça peut être parce
que ces enveloppes vous pouvez les
utiliser son personne ne le sache jamais
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions jean christophe
lagarde président de l'uvéite député de
seine-saint-denis